foreign
[Music]
the top story is live from the Sky News
City Studio
UK economy flat lines in February but is
now bigger than it was going into the
pandemic
Tesco profits hit us the supermarket
battles Rising costs and what it
describes as an incredibly tough year
for customers
the UK's largest ever battery looks set
to be built after manufacturer Infinity
receives an 11 million pound government
grant
Ford gets regulatory approval to bring
hands-free driving technology to
European roads and
aren't you a little short for a Storm
Trooper I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here to
rescue you
I must speak to Disney's newest Luke
Skywalker about the dangers AI could
pose to the acting profession
foreign
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City the UK economy
flatlined during February according to
figures published this morning the
office for National statistics said
gross domestic product was unchanged
during the month slightly below the 0.1
percent growth that the market had been
expecting however an upward revision to
the January GDP figure from 0.3 percent
to 0.4 percent means that the UK economy
is now bigger than it was going into the
pandemic the ons said UK GDP is now 0.3
percent larger than it was in February
2020 we're joining me now is our
business correspondent uh gerprit no one
no these figures really good a bit of a
cure its egg
yeah that's right we know that the
economy managed to avoid recession
towards the end of last year it defied
expectations again in January by posting
uh 0.4 growth but I'm afraid that
doesn't change the overall picture which
is one of economic stagnation and
figures out by the office for National
statistics to office for National
statistics Today Show that the economy
flatlined uh with growth of naught
percent in February and that was largely
due to Industrial action we know that
teachers civil servants and healthcare
workers all went on strike in February
and this weighed heavily on public
sector output but some of that should
drop out of the data soon enough uh
hopefully as deals are struck
but if we look past that the economy is
still pretty anemic and the full effect
of rising interest rates has not yet
been felt the outlook for the year ahead
is pretty bleak the international
monetary fund earlier this week said
that the economy would shrink by 0.3
this year making Britain the worst
performer of the world's largest
economies so if you combine weak growth
with high inflation I'm afraid that that
doesn't bode well for our living
standards economists believe that
disposable incomes in the UK are set for
their biggest drop in 50 years so I'm
afraid there's not a huge amount of good
news
like
just a bit of breaking news to bring you
that we've just received a body has been
found washed up on a beach following a
search operation off Brighton Palace
Pier during the heavy Winds of storm
Noah that is from Sussex police will
bring you more on that news story as
soon as we get it let me tell you about
some of the other business news stories
around this morning though and Tesco
warned today that its profits will be
flat this year as it seeks to insulate
its customers from the impact of
inflation the UK's leader in grossing
retailer grocery retailer reported an
adjusted operating profit of 2.6 billion
pounds for the year to the 25th of
February that was down 6.9 percent on
the same period 12 months earlier which
the company said reflected lower sales
volumes in the UK and the Republic of
Ireland and the impact of price Cuts
well Ken Murphy Tesco's chief executive
said that the company had faced
unprecedented levels of inflation in the
prices it pays its supplies for their
products as well as in the cost of
running its own operations he said the
company was however expecting inflation
to moderate during the second half of
this year Well Tesco's headline pre-tax
profits halved to 1 billion pounds and
that was mainly due to impairment
charges on its property estate the
shares are currently some two percent
ahead
the cyber security company dark Trace
warned this morning that continuing
uncertainty in the macroeconomic
environment continues to have an impact
on its ability to win new customers dark
Trace whose customers include Alliance
Airbus and the Royal Mint said that
requirements to hold or cut spending was
making potential customers more
reluctant to run product trials but the
company said it was excited about
opportunities created by a recent
upgrade to its email service which is
able to detect novel email attacks 13
days earlier on average than other email
security tools the shares are up some
one and a half percent right now
and the household goods group behind
Imperial leather soap careex hand gel
and original Source shower gel said this
morning it is on course to hit its fully
profit targets after sales during the
most recent quarter grew by 6.2 percent
P said cousins said that the sales
growth during the three months to the
4th of March was achieved by a
combination of price increases and by
customer switching to more expensive
lines it also highlighted new product
launches which included an extension of
Morning Fresh Australia's leading
dishwashing liquid into other areas
now a Ford this morning became the first
traditional car manufacturer to
introduce so-called hands-off eyes on
Advanced Driver assistance technology in
Europe Ford blue Cruise the car Maker's
Advanced Driver assistance system has
already been launched in the United
States and Canada but has now been
approved for use in the UK by the
department for transport it can be used
on some 3 700 kilometers of roads here
that have been designed that's
appropriate for such technology but it
will initially only be available to
owners of the company's all-electric
Mustang Mac E SUV model where the launch
comes just six months after Ford and
Volkswagen closed Argo AI an autonomous
vehicle startup well joining me now is
the manufacturing managing director of
Ford UK in Ireland Lisa Franken Lisa
good morning to you so what can this
technology do and what it can't it do
okay good morning Ian so as you said
it's a hands-free driver assistance
technology and so what that means in
English is when you're in the vehicle
you can set the speed you want to travel
at you can set the distance that you
want to travel out from the car in front
you can take your hands off the wheel
and your hands off the pedals and as
long as you're paying attention and
watching the road the car will will dry
for you so it's a much more relaxing
um much more pleasurable Motorway Drive
and what have you had to do to convince
the department for transport to uh allow
its use in the UK
so we've had a period of time where
we've worked with the Department of
Transport where we shared our data with
them they've come and seen how we've
tested the vehicle and they've also
tested the vehicle so we've had a really
collaborative approach they've actually
been incredibly supportive of helping us
get here and yes and they're really
confident that we meet all the safety
requirements and they've given us the
exception to be able to go live with
this product today
now drivers will only be allowed to take
their hands off the steering wheel
whether when they're in a so-called Blue
Zone how will they know that they're in
one
Lisa can you hear me
sorry Ian I've just lost you a little
bit so would you mind repeating that
question for me yeah sure I was just
saying no no drivers are only going to
be allowed to take their hands off the
steering wheel when they're in a
so-called Blue Zone how will they know
that they're in one
so they don't need to know the car knows
so
um you can pre-condition the vehicle to
say that you want it
um Drive hands-free and and when you
enter a Blue Zone the car the the
display in the car will prompt you and
tell you that that it's here to take
your hands off the wheel and then when
you exit the Blue Zone so for example if
you pull off the motorway again the
vehicle will prompt you to say that you
need to put your hands back on the wheel
and take full control right now it is
quite a soft launch as I said in the
introduction it's only going to be in
the Mustang Mackie initially how many of
those particular models do you expect to
sell this year
so we'll probably start around about
five thousand of those this year
um and obviously we're looking at as we
move forward to maybe roll the
technology out onto other vehicles but
at the minute as you said it's only on
our VR mustard Mackie or electric
vehicle so when would you expect this
kind of technology to become standard in
Ford vehicles in the UK
that's a really good question one that I
just can't answer for you at the minute
I guess we'll see how I take outcome
object comes we're not we're not
planning um we're planning actually to
launch it as a subscription service
because we recognize
um that this might be something that
customers want to flexibly use so
um you may decide that you're not going
to be driving on motorways and you don't
want to have your monthly subscription
so you can stop that or you may decide
that you're going to be driving a lot on
Motorway driving and then you can opt
into the subscription
um and so so we decided to go down and
wrote a subscription-based um offering
for the product rather than
standardizing across the range now this
technology as I said in the introduction
it's been in use in the US and Canada
for quite a while now what's Ford
learned from its rollout in those
countries
so that's right we've got almost 200 000
um vehicles on the road in Canada and
North America and they've done over 16
million miles so the first thing I say
to you has been
um no accident so it's been really safe
we've seen that that about half those
miles are being driven using blue Cruise
technology it's been really really well
received by customers
um and actually
um the response has been really positive
which has really encouraged us to then
move into Europe and launch it starting
in Great Britain
and Lisa put this into context for me if
you would please of Ford's overall
driverless technology strategy right now
because as I mentioned uh you and VW
closed Argo AIO only about six months
ago
so we have decided to focus our
technology very much around driver
assistance and around
um if you like a retail customer
experience rather than looking at a
business experience so fully we've
stepped away from those fully autonomous
vehicles driving around maybe delivering
pizzas or whatever where we're looking
at technology that that's focused around
um more of a retail a customer or an
individual Driving Experience so this
technology sits very firmly in driver
assistance so the driver
um is a is a in control or responsible
for the vehicle and this is just helping
them do that so we would say this is
level two autonomy the next stage for Us
is around level three which again is a
bit more about the vehicle taking
control but when we're not progressing
as aggressively fully autonomous
vehicles um as we have been before
and why is that
I just think we see just more benefit
for customers if you think about what
Ford's been about it's about
um
kind of bringing technology to the
masses if you think about Henry Ford in
the 1920s and his mass production lines
if you think about quickly if you think
about abs and we just see that this um
implementation of the technology is much
more valuable to our customers and
that's we're going to focus our efforts
in the in the UK and North America
all right Lisa gotta leave it there
appreciate you joining me today
thank you thanks Ian
and before you all write in and email me
the strap in the top corner there said
Dunton in bedfordshire and of course
everyone knows Dunton is actually in
Essex although I think Lisa was speaking
to us from bedfordshire but not sure
where precisely
now what is expected to be the UK's
largest battery has come a step closer
with the awarding of an 11 million pound
Grant by the department for energy
security and Net Zero to the Scottish
energy storage manufacturer Infinity
Energy Systems the company says the 30
megawatt hour battery will help to
balance the UK electricity grid support
the renewable energy transition and
provide a boost to UK energy security it
claims the battery will store enough
energy including low-cost Renewables to
meet the daily electricity needs of more
than three and a half thousand UK homes
well joining me now is the chief
development officer at Infinity Jonathan
Mariner Jonathan welcome to you this is
a Vanadium flow battery uh you better
explain to the uninitiated what that is
uh thank you Ian of course um what I
won't do is go into the technology in
too much detail um but suffice to say
unlike a conventional battery such as
lithium-ion we store the power and
energy uh separately in in the battery
so the energy is stored separately in a
liquid form um it's in tanks and then
you flow that liquid across a cell stack
which is the core IP which is where the
the power is generated but actually may
be easier to focus on the benefits of
this technology so it is ideal for
connecting to renewable energy it works
best when it's being cycled frequently
um so therefore sort of with wind and
solar as that sort of Cycles or Cycles
on and off it doesn't wear out with use
it's got a 25 year life it's critically
it's safe it doesn't catch fire at all
it's reliable economic to run and at the
end of its useful life at least 25 year
lives it's completely recyclable
um so we we sort of tend to turn it the
the Swiss army knife of batteries in
that it can offer a very wide range of
services
what in what way does it differ though
from other storage uh Technologies such
as Lithium-ion batteries
um so it sits very complementary
alongside lithium ion lithium ion um is
typically a solution for the sort of one
to one to two to three hour range
um as we all know with a without with
our phones um yeah lithium batteries do
degrade uh potentially quite quickly
over time and with high cycling a flow
battery
um works best when it is being cycled
and lasts for a much longer period in
terms of uh length of the asset so 25
years but also for longer duration so if
you need to extend the time scale for
the battery and you just add more liquid
so we will run sort of a thread
typically a four to ten hour range
whereas lithium will sit
um in front of that in the sort of one
to one to two hour range um but we're
also capable of offering a full range of
services to the grid
um so there'd be that high frequency
response uh load shifting or a number of
other services which are and the
battery's capable of doing and so how
much Vanadium is in the composition of
the battery
uh so uh the Vanadium sits in a Vanadium
electrolyte solution and again I won't
go into
um detail here as to how much sits in
sits in there uh but that's basically a
sulfuric acid and Vanadium Vanadium mix
Palladium itself is the 20th most uh
common uh element on the Earth's crust
uh typically it's a byproduct from a
mining process uh or a um a catalyst um
uh sort of uh sort of catalyst recycling
process so typically it's a byproduct
rather than being primary mined you've
uh you've kind of preempted my next
question which is going to be I mean I
think Vanadium is very commonly used in
construction and and steel sector in
particular you're not going to be facing
competition for resources
uh we don't we don't believe so we work
very closely uh with Vanadium producers
uh there's an organization called
lanotech which is the trade Association
for valadium uh we we regularly attend
their conferences and there are a lot of
um sort of providers in that area that
are looking to run pulp production and
so we believe there is a plentiful
Supply available
um and actually they're looking at us to
prove the demonstration of the
technology
um and therefore to ramp up the
production that's what's exciting about
this award from the UK government is it
enables us to prove at scale
um what is a very significant asset
um and therefore they will be able to
ramp up their production and to be able
to fulfill our needs and the battery is
going to be manufactured at your bath
gate facility in West Lothian what is
going to be the cost of building it and
how long will it take
um so um I'm not going to go to
necessary costs here it's an 11 million
pound Grant from the from the UK
government that's matched uh match
funded by our partners so
um yeah that's a a sort of project north
of north of 20 million pounds
um it will be uh we're looking to have
that um installed in 2024 and
commissioned in 2024
um such that it's uh readily um it's
finished by the the time scale the end
so mid mid 2025 when the project
technically has to be has to be
completed by uh but we're confident it
will be installed by by then
um and you know for us that will then
lead us to the next stage in our
Evolution it's a real game changer for
us it's a bachelor that's six times
larger than the one we have installed at
the moment which is the energy super Hub
Oxford
um and for us uh that sort of is a real
step forward improving to to our
customers but also to the to the to the
grid that this can really be a solution
uh to on on the route to Net Zero and
dealing with energy security issues in
the UK now as you said say the grant was
dependent on you getting matched funding
from a business partner you've said that
you've got that match funding you're not
naming your partner though so I
understand it uh we're not at the moment
uh we we've said we saw heads of terms
but then hey we're completing uh
Contracting with them but also
um that partner is in the process of
securing the site
um and um at the moment we they've asked
us not to disclose who who they are so
um that's sort of that's that's very
well but highly confident that they are
there and ready ready to go in the time
scales needed very good it's a
fascinating topic hope to hear more from
you in the future on this Jonathan
thanks for joining me today very kind
thank you
well still to come here on Ian King live
have a look at how Global markets are
doing this Thursday morning stay tuned
foreign
[Music]
course of living crisis has exacerbated
the number of fake ads for Holiday
cottages and places to stay on social
media and now with the passport delays
there's an awful lot of ads advertising
appointments Fast Track delays for Fast
Track services and promising you a
passport within a really unrealistic
time frame so you know poor unsuspecting
holiday makers are paying and losing
their money I mean broadly if it seems
too good to be true it probably is you
know that's the bottom line in terms of
holiday cottages and the like do your
research you know don't I think that
these scammers they um you know they
exploit people who are panicking who are
in a rush or desperate for a holiday do
your research don't jump in don't pay
cash pay with something a phone phone
the number research the website make
sure it's a um you know a credible
source and don't pay cash
with the passport
um scans they're actually advertising
appointments so for the fast track and
the premium service you need to book an
appointment before you can actually
use the service and uh you know so it's
confusing and you know holiday makers
are sitting online for hours on end
waiting for these appointments so you
know you can forgive them for rushing in
what seems like a really good
opportunity just don't you've got
consumer rights you've got protection
with your credit card so the payment is
traceable the credit card company can
see where the money's gone and if you've
paid in good faith and you are um you've
followed the terms and conditions of
your credit card then yes you've got a
much better chance of getting your money
back than if you've just paid cash where
it's untraceable nobody knows what
you've given when you've given it and
who to so um yeah definitely pay with a
credit card if you can
[Music]
welcome back now while Ramadan is
commonly associated with the farce that
takes place daily from sunrise to sunset
the vast majority of Muslim households
typically spend more on food food during
the month that's because of the
importance of iftar the fast-breaking
evening meal an occasion to be enjoyed
with family and friends however during
the cost of living crisis there are
concerns many families will struggle to
provide iftar meals this Ramadan so the
manchester-based charity human appeal is
joining forces with Hellman's to provide
free iftar for all food Parcels for
those in need well joining me now is
Abid Shah of the UK programs manager at
human appeal Abbott good to see you this
morning for those people who aren't up
on Muslim Customs just explain to me the
importance of of the iftar
yeah thanks for having me um the iftar
meal as you've rightly mentioned is the
meal that's typically Muslims have in
the evening to to break their fasts and
as you've mentioned this Ramadan be
found through research an increased
number of people who are concerned about
how they how they essentially sustain
themselves I mean it's an issue that
you're seeing across the country but in
particular in relationship if there are
lots of people who are concerned about
the cost of living crisis concerned
about the cost of food items and we are
trying to do a little bit about that
how much would a British Muslim
households typically spend extra on
iftar meals
um I mean typical with with festivals um
as you know with the Christmas period
all Ramadan does does a general desire
to to increase uh or change the food
items that you typically eat so
um from our research we found
um around 50 of people um talking about
spending around 91 pounds per week
um and just a general increase uh 65 of
people uh mentioning that of course just
this Ramadan in comparison to previous
ramadans and previous years uh a rising
costs is something that's concerning
them
so tell me what's in the food Parcels I
gather you work with a well-known nurse
Chef to develop ingredients and recipes
that's right so we're working with
Hellman's as mentioned uh so we've
partnered with helmets for this for this
campaign and we're working with the
Ophelia's kitchen uh well known Chef
Ophelia vegan and each food puzzle
contains a variety of items that uh a
household would typically find so we
have food items like pasta and rice and
uh
um pot noodles uh chickpeas baked beans
um amongst other items long life milk
lentils and Ophelia's kitchen have very
kindly provided us with a couple of
recipes so in addition to providing the
food parcel itself
the intention here is try and encourage
households to not waste food and to be
more conscious about wastage of food
which is also something that we've found
households to be concerned about in
relation to uh the cost of living crisis
now households that want to Avail
themselves of this service have to pick
up the parcels at uh sites I think
you're running at Birmingham Luton and
in Bolton what sort of take-up have you
had so far
um so we've had a a kind of a mixed
response I suppose in in Bolton recently
the the our partners on the ground
homeless agent UK spoke about being
inundated with calls unfortunately a lot
of families a lot of people reaching out
to them are inquiring about the food
Parcels in in London and in in uh
Birmingham again we found uh you know
locals local families getting in touch
with our respective Partners there and
reaching out to them
um so that has that there's definitely a
concern there with the families reaching
out and and the fact that
um you know they've seen the news
articles that they've seen the fact that
these uh food Parcels are available and
they want to make use of
it and how much is this initiative cost
uh this initiative the initiative hasn't
ended yet it's ongoing so uh it's hard
to tell how much it'll end up costing I
mean we're looking at potentially uh
providing over 11 000 food items
individual food items through the
parcels
um so it's it's not quite done yet it'll
be hard to give a kind of a exact figure
at the moment
all right Abid good to see you this
morning and congratulations on a very
worthwhile initiative thank you
okay thanks a lot
[Music]
well the US dollar eased last night
following the softer than expected March
inflation figures which have raised
expectations that next month's predicted
interest rate rise from the U.S federal
reserve could be the last in this
cyclist you can see the pound is ahead
by nearly a quarter of one percent right
now against the Greenback it's more or
less unchanged against the Euro The
single currency model similarly up a
quarter one percent against the dollar
on the equity markets last night
sell-off on Wall Street was followed by
mixed trade overnight in the Asia
Pacific region there were gains for
Tokyo and for Hong Kong but declines in
Sydney Shanghai and in Mumbai well in
Europe markets are also pretty mixed
this morning as you can see only the
Kakarot right now among leading uh
Continental European stock indices in
positive territory and I suspect that
might be because one of the main talking
points this morning is lvmh which is not
only the world's biggest luxury goods
group it's also the largest company in
France and on the uh cat current and it
shares their ahead by nearly five
percent this morning after stronger than
expected results which were published
after the market closed last night well
here in London the ftse 100 is in
positive is in positive territory very
very just it's one of the half points to
the good more or less uh unchanged there
right now property and energy stocks
Weighing on the index to an extent there
there are some gainers to mention though
the house builders Taylor wimping
Barrett are among leading Blue Chip
gainers this morning that's on the back
of some supportive comment from I'm one
of the Brokers HSBC this morning uh
Taylor wimpy up two and a quarter
percent barreled up by two percent all
of the house builders are ahead right
now and Tesco I mentioned them a little
earlier on the program it Shares are
ahead by nearly two percent right now as
well one and three quarter percent in
fact right now as ever at this time of
the year on a Thursday a lot of stocks
have gone ex-dividend today in other
words they're trading for the first time
without the rights to the latest payout
uh the batch this morning includes
Lloyd's banking group and uh Smurfette
Kappa the paper and packaging giant if
your shareholders in both of those
countries companies don't worry that is
just an automatic adjustment to reflect
the fact that those have gone ex-div
today outside the ftsee Oxford
instruments Shares are ahead by some
five and a half percent that's after the
company raised its profits like look
well the bathroom accessories make a
Norcross its Shares are ahead by some
seven percent on a trading update as for
the oil price we can see it on the
screen there right now it took another
Upward Bound last night to hit its
highest level since the end of January
it's held on to those gains this morning
about a Brent crude will currently cost
you eighty seven dollars 38 cents a
barrel that is uh just under a tenth of
one percent right now higher on the
session joining me now is the global
head of brand at scope markets James
Hughes James good to see you this
morning
um very interesting move in in the
dollar right now I mean people do seem
to be pricing in the end of the rate
tightening cycle
yeah that's that's right I mean I think
the the key Focus that we we have all
had this week it has been the fed and
those inflation numbers uh yesterday and
and that's kind of got everyone's uh
talking this morning around if that rate
hike is now going to be that's
potentially on the table uh is going to
be taken off the table I think I think
what we saw yesterday was was
interesting because we saw really two
sides to this number one we saw the the
slightly softer inflation numbers and
and yes that that has one side but the
FED minutes uh later in the evening
yesterday also painted that story of of
uh recession so the the minutes hinting
that we could see a recession come in uh
later in the year on the back of the
banking crisis and even though that
banking crisis has has what seems to be
as eased on the top level at the moment
there does still seem to be a lot of
withdrawals happening is better within
some of these Banks so there is still
that story there that's a that's a
little bit more nervy than than what
we'd expect so that's why we're seeing
this this move in the US dollar as well
and that that continuous talk around the
fact that we we could now see this
potential rate height coming off the
table and that would potentially then
follow the likes of Canada who have now
stopped raising rates as well it just
when we get to that stage it's how long
they then Plateau before we start seeing
them coming down yeah it's very
interesting I mean the FX Market clearly
is uh looking at uh the way that
Sterling's trading against the dollar
right now
I mean the the money markets are kind of
assuming it would be one and done from
the bank of England but I get the sense
in the FX Market they think there might
be a bit more to come
yeah I think the UK is an interesting
one as well because I think if you look
at how the the economy is performing
there it's not like inflation in the
likes of the US or in other areas where
we've seen that substantially down from
the highest that we've seen previously
inflation is still incredibly high in
the use date but underlying some of the
economic data Still Remains remains
pretty resilient to be perfectly honest
so I think that the feeling there is how
do you control that how do you control
inflation well the rate hikes at the
moment aren't necessarily doing that you
know the the rate hikes continue to to
leave us in this situation where it's
pushing the cost of living up uh higher
and is making everything everything
tougher for for everyone uh the question
then comes is what do you do with the
economy the GDP numbers this morning uh
the the monthly GDP numbers were were
pretty much uh flat uh came in at zero
they're only the monthly ones but there
is the school of thought is is maybe the
way to control inflation is for the the
economy to get worse to head into
recession as the bank of England expect
and and that will eventually bring
inflation down and then we'll stop that
rate cycle but for now we expect yet one
more in May and and the the safe money
is in the fact that that then continues
uh to blend Plateau towards the end of
the year but it just depends on how
stubborn that inflation number remains
yeah just go back something you said
earlier James you mentioned the Bank of
Canada obviously uh kept rates on the
hold yesterday are you seeing much
activity in the Canadian dollar just now
there's not too much you know but I
think because there's the because they
have become that that that almost that
Shining Light of of we're stopping the
the rate hikes and now we're looking to
to be pretty pretty uh stable in terms
of those rates there it does tend to be
a focus within there of course there's
the oil angle as well from a commodity
based currency and we see that from from
flows from our client perspective we see
that that movement into those
commodity-based currencies because of
the the the movements that we see uh in
the oil price so we do tend to get quite
a lot of interest in in those pairs and
when you get that added focus of of the
Bank of Canada moving ahead and being
that uh moving to that next step we do
tend to get quite a lot of interest in
those pairs and so for the Canadian
dollar it's one that our clients
especially take a look at
all right James gotta leave it there
good to see you this morning thank you
thank you
just a bit of uh breaking uh news to
bring that we've received in the last
few minutes This concerns uh Silvio
Berlusconi the former Italian prime
minister so we've been reporting he is
in the hospital right now we've just had
an update from his Hospital doctors in
Milan they say that Sylvia berlusconi's
Health continues continue to improve but
he remains in intensive care he's being
treated for a type of chronic leukemia
we'll bring you more on that of course
when we get it Silvio Berlusconi 86
years old I think right now
still to come here onion King live why
the UK government has invested in a firm
which is fighting climate change by
growing and harvesting seaweed don't go
away
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back now there's been a lot of
attention paid recently to carbon
capture and storage technology but it's
not the only way of removing carbon from
the atmosphere stockport-based sea
Fields is aiming to remove billions of
tons of carbon from the Atlantic Ocean
by cultivating sargassum seaweed which
has a unique ability to sequester and
remove carbon it's just been awarded a
grant worth a quarter of a million
pounds from innovate UK the UK's
Innovation agency well joining me now is
the co-founder and chief executive of
seafield's John Auckland John welcome to
you how does uh sargassum sequester
carbon
um high-end yeah so sargassum is is
quite unique in nature in that it grows
so prolifically and um it doesn't need
very many nutrients to do it so it
doubles in size every 14 days and in
fact in lab conditions we've managed to
get it to double in size in as few as
five days
um so if you think solving the climate
crisis is about capturing as much carbon
in biomass as possible
um so if you can get stuff to grow
really quickly plants to grow really
quickly then you're going to by default
catch more carbon so that's the idea
with sargassum and and what's also great
about it is
um you have huge amounts of space in the
South Atlantic to work with
um if you think of uh trying to grow
stuff on land
um we're running out of space on land to
grow stuff and and climate change is
only going to make that worse
um so we can take uh this vast unused
area of the South Atlantic gyre and grow
seaweed there
um Harvest it uh bail it sink it to the
bottom of the ocean it will stay there
for geological time scales
so how do you get it to the bottom of
the ocean
um so uh it's quite buoyant so it's got
these these small bladders on it you've
got to pop those bladders um so what we
do is we bring it up onto the deck of a
ship we uh run it for a screw press and
squeeze all the juice out of it and the
liquid about 82 of the liquid comes out
that way we then Shred the sargassum to
pop all those bladders bail it using an
industrial baling machine that that's
used in agriculture
um and then Chuck it over the side of
the ship and that it achieves negative
buoyancy it drops to the bottom of the
ocean pretty quickly
um we're talking about 4 000 plus meters
of debt five thousand six thousand
meters ideally
um and down there the pressure is so
great and
um because we've removed all the the
nutrients in that screw press process
we've also removed any incentive for
microbial life to um to eat the Bales so
um that's why we're quite confident that
the the carbon will stay down there for
for incredibly long time and it's
important as you say to put it on the
seabed because I mean when it floats to
the surface it's pretty unappealing
isn't it when it rots on the beach it
releases hydrogen sulfide I think
yeah so um it's in the news quite a lot
recently actually that this sort of 5
000 mile blob of seaweed that's heading
to to Florida and the Caribbean um
that's actually another runaway effect
of climate change um ironically uh where
winds blown um so I guess amounts of the
sargasso sea is proliferated
um in an area that it it shouldn't be
and so then it washes up on beaches and
rots and causes all sorts of problems so
we're actually going to the Caribbean
first to tackle some of that problem
we're going to create a farm which we're
going to install from as early as
December with fundraising at the moment
for that farm um on on crowdcube um
and so uh once we've installed that that
will catch that sargassum and stop it
from overbeaching
um and then we can uh ship that out to
the Abyssal plane 4 000 meters and sink
it and stop what is currently an
ecological disaster at the same time
and I mean you mentioned that you're
fundraising right now what what is the
what is the business model in terms of
turning a profit on this very worthwhile
venture
so we're quite reliant on the carbon
markets which is the vulnerability that
we're not particularly happy about
um so we want to try and think a bit
more creatively about how we can fund it
um what we're going to do is we're going
to sell Parcels of of our farm
um in advance to to corporates or even
retail investors that want to find
climate action
um they can then receive those carbon
credits and sell them if they want or
they can you know use it as part of
their own sort of offsetting um
strategies
um and we're working with a partner
pharmacist company called just carbon to
to deliver that
um but we can also extract some valuable
resources out of it as well so once we
run it through the smooth press the the
liquid we get off is is um most of those
micronutrients come back out so as we
recycle them and they're actually quite
valuable to agriculture
um they can be used as a an organic
fertilizer for example so we're looking
at different sort of Pathways where we
can valorize that seaweed
um and another another route as well as
to turn it into these feed stocks for
Industries so bio after biomethanol
these feed stops that are used by the
Plastics industry and and ultimately the
fuel industry right so it's an another
double benefit that we can Abate these
otherwise fossil fuel dependent um
Industries
all right and very briefly if you beat
the kind John obviously you're operating
at a proof of concept stage at the
moment how long do you think it will be
before you can prove that this is viable
yeah so there's kind of two stages that
group of clients are at the first stage
is is our pilot fund that we want to
install in the Caribbean um from
December
um and that proves that we can generate
revenues and we can sync the the the
Bales and that they stay down there and
we can generate carbon credit Revenue
the next stage then is going to the open
ocean the South Atlantic giant that's a
huge huge step huge undertaking huge
investment needed
um and that's going to take us a few
years to get that
all right John best of luck with it
thanks for joining me today good to see
you thank you
foreign
[Music]
have a look at this morning's business
pages and the financial times leads both
its print and digital editions right now
with the comments yesterday from Andrew
Bailey in which the bank of England
Governor indicated that the UK might
need to increase its limit for
guaranteed deposits above the current
level of 85 000 pounds Mr Bailey said
the current UK scheme was unlikely to
work as intended for smaller Banks such
as Silicon Valley Bank which of course
had to be rescued last month the Ft also
carries a column from Megan green who
was confirmed this week as the newest
member of the bank of England's monetary
policy committee and in her column today
Megan green says that while the
commercial property sector is not is
under pressure right now it is not
facing a 2008 style crisis so relief for
us all I'm sure the times leads its
business pages with yesterday's warning
from the U.S federal reserve that
America would suffer a mild recession
this year the times also reveals that
the former Chancellor quasi quateng held
emergency talks with the head of the
international monetary fund over the
institution's rebuke of his mini budget
last Autumn The Daily Telegraph also
leads with comments from Andrew Bailey
yesterday but it's honed in on his
warning that the rise of social media
means that bank runs are faster and more
dangerous than ever before the telegraph
also carries a report on yesterday's
warning from JP Morgan to its investment
bankers that they will face punishment
for failing to work from the office and
that came acid ordered its senior staff
back to their desks five days a week or
joining me this morning is the Wall
Street journals editor for Europe the
Middle East and Africa Toro Parker Toro
good to see you this morning before we
talk about what's in the newspapers I'm
I must talk to you about Evan gershkovic
your colleague who's in prison in Russia
right now there was a very very moving
event in the journals New York Newsroom
yesterday I think we can put a picture
of it up to uh show the viewers
here it comes
they're absolutely Marvel real I was
very moved by that picture
yeah so
um
as as many of you will know Evan
um was arrested in Russia two weeks ago
yesterday
um uh he was he was detained
um illegally detained the the US has now
said uh officially that that they
considered an illegal detention uh he
was just doing his job as a journalist
and um obviously this is extremely
chilling uh for journalists around the
world and and for those
um uh still operating uh in Russia but
this is this was
um us marking uh that two weeks there's
been this huge outpouring of support uh
for him from uh those in The Newsroom
he's a very beloved member of The
Newsroom and a very talented journalist
but also more broadly uh Beyond The
Newsroom in other media organizations
and diplomatic channels and governments
around the world so so yes it was a
great uh moment and we will continue to
push hard uh to get him home yeah it's
good to hear I mean reading the
journal's uh coverage on this story I
mean the the amazing thing is he
absolutely obviously loved Russia I mean
he was obviously of Russian Heritage but
he obviously really really loved the
country for its own sake
absolutely and he was there to tell the
story of Russia how it's being affected
uh by the conflict in Ukraine and
covering uh you know a wide range of
topics from the economy to the impact on
society uh and other things so um you
know he was there doing his job he was
doing an excellent job and and this is a
a um a really really uh sad day for for
journalists and we will hopefully get
him back doing his job again uh as soon
as we possibly can absolutely hashtag I
stand with Evan
um let's talk about some stories and uh
torald obviously uh one of the big
events this week has been ey pulling the
plug on its uh proposed hiving off of
its Consulting arm I mean you've given
it again big coverage today in the
journal
yeah I mean it's a pretty extraordinary
story this where um you know an advisory
firm has gone through this process uh
itself and you know spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on breaking apart
the Consulting business uh from the
audit business in order to avoid
conflicts of interest and then after all
this money and all this time finding
that the US Partners didn't actually
want to go through with it and agree
with it so um it's a pretty embarrassing
moment for the company I think there are
concerns about whether they'll lose
staff on the back of it but really just
a huge amount of time and effort gone
into this
um for it all to unravel at the last
minute yes extraordinary situation isn't
it now what about uh the FED minutes
last night we were talking about the
impact uh earlier on in the program this
has had on the dollar but uh it really
feels as though the FED thinks the
recession's on the way
yes look I think the challenge that the
FED has at the moment is you know
they've raised rates incredibly
aggressively
um as one of your previous speakers said
I think you know we're probably getting
towards the end of the tightening cycle
at this point but you know we've had
some full storms on uh inflation before
we've had it ticked down and then come
up again core inflation is still pretty
strong and you know we're still you know
monetary policy operates with a lag so
we're still going to see the effects of
those rate hikes come through the system
over the coming months and we've already
seen some of the issues that's caused in
financial markets and in the banking
system with svb
um going past we saw obviously what
happened to Credit Suisse which is I
think part of these Tremors going
through the system as rates have gone up
so much so the fed's trying to balance a
slowing economy with still pretty high
inflation if you look at core inflation
in the US it's still it's still pretty
high
um and the fact that this this operates
with a lag and so you'll see the impacts
continue to work their way through the
system and so as they balance all of
that you know I think a pause is is
quite likely but again you know markets
are trying to work out whether you're
going to see a sharp slow down in growth
or whether you're going to see inflation
pick up again as it has over the last
year or two when there's been these four
stones and so I think people are still
trying to work out where this goes
honestly yeah it's a good point you make
on the lag I mean it is one hell of a
lag right now because uh it seems from
this side of the Atlantic the US economy
is absolutely thriving right now I mean
another strong set of jobs numbers last
week for example yeah it is and I think
it you know it is an incredibly
resilient economy to proved that time
and again but you know these interest
rate hikes they do affect people over
time the U.S system is different from
the UK system so here in the UK a lot of
people will be facing
um you know mortgage hikes the rent of
their mortgages will go up when they
refinance from a two-year or five-year
fixed over time in the US it's mainly
30-year fixed mortgages so you don't
have that consumer refinancing shock
that comes through quickly but that said
there will be
um you know less availability of credit
because of these Financial shocks in the
US and also you know as people in the
banking system fight for deposits and
have to raise rates the cost of money is
going up through the system so as people
borrow as companies borrow those rates
will slowly tick up over time as people
refinance and you will see that effect
hit people so it's really hard in such a
complex and financialized economy to
understand how that's going to hit and
when it's going to hit all right Toro
Before I Let You Go obviously Joe
Biden's in uh Ireland right now is that
getting uh a lot of interest from the
readers
absolutely now look I think um you know
any presidential trip obviously
um uh gets a lot of interest but in this
case you know going back to his roots I
think yeah for sure this is something
that um uh both Us in the UK but also
the American readers are interested in
all right Toro good to see you this
morning thanks for joining me
still to come here on Ian King live
aren't you a little short for a Storm
Trooper
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here to rescue
you
the battle begins here on Earth to
protect the rights of performers as the
entertainment industry Embraces AI stay
tuned
[Music]
cost of living crisis has exacerbated
the number of
um fake ads for Holiday cottages and
places to stay on social media and now
with the passport delays um there's an
awful lot of ads advertising
appointments Fast Track delays for Fast
Track services and promising you a
passport within a really unrealistic
time frame so you know poor unsuspecting
holiday makers are paying and losing
their money I mean broadly if it seems
too good to be true it probably is you
know that's the bottom line in terms of
holiday cottages and the like do your
research you know don't I think that
these scammers they um you know they
exploit people who are panicking who are
in a rush or desperate for a holiday do
your research don't jump in don't pay
cash pay with something a phone phone
the number research the website make
sure it's a um you know a credible
source and don't pay cash with the
passport
scams they're actually advertising
appointments so for the fast track and
the premium service you need to book an
appointment before you can actually
use the service and uh you know so it's
confusing and you know holiday makers
are sitting online for hours on end
waiting for these appointments so you
know you can forgive them for rushing in
what seems like a really good
opportunity just don't you've got
consumer rights you've got protection
with your credit card so the payment is
traceable the credit card company can
see where the money's gone and if you've
paid in good faith and you are um you've
followed the terms and conditions of
your credit card then yes you've got a
much better chance of getting your money
back than if you've just paid cash where
it's untraceable nobody knows what
you've given when you've given it and
who to so
um yeah definitely pay with a credit
card if you can
[Music]
thank you
foreign
made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back well until now people in
the creative Industries such as actors
and singers have been confident that
artificial intelligence won't replace
them but a growing trend for companies
to recreate actors voices with AI and
then use them for other projects has
become a cause of great concern for
performers last year Darth Vader himself
James Earl Jones sold the rights to his
voice to Disney for an undisclosed sum a
deal that has spooked other actors were
joining me now from Darth Vader to Luke
Skywalker I'm joined by the actor and
star of last year's Lego Star Wars game
David menkin David welcome to you how
accurate is this technology
it's just getting better and better
um AI contributed 3.7 billion pounds to
the UK economy last year it's just going
to Skyrocket it keeps learning and if
the UK government does what it says it's
going to do it's going to learn very
very fast and it's going to put a lot of
people out of work
so how big a threat is this to the
acting profession
well the UK wants to become an AI
superpower but uh experts and the
government agree that AI needs
regulation so a white paper with
guidelines on responsible use has been
published but there's actually no
statutory footing there as a carrot the
government has been proposing a text and
data mining exception to the UK
copyright law
essentially allowing AI companies the
ability to use all published work in the
UK for free
now there's been a lot of pushback from
my union Equity the musicians unions Etc
and the government agreed to go back to
the drawing board but
um it seems to be back on the table
based on the spring budget
are you already seeing examples of voice
over work drying up
well it yes it's going to start
affecting people uh non-playable
characters so if you are in a big game
and you're meeting people as you go
around the game that kind of stuff is
going to be populated by AI soon
I think it's already starting to happen
just a certain extent but what's
happening to us is that there's actually
free software out there that's uh
cloning our voices so what's happening
right now is
um my colleagues and I are in games
where people clone our voices and then
go in and they mob the game and then
they get us to say racist misogynist
horrible things and it sounds like it's
us so it feels a bit like identity theft
absolutely I mean have you got any legal
comeback on that can you can you
copyright your name your voice
well unfortunately uh well we can
there's intellectual property but you
know the the government's framework on
that is uh way out of date uh the
copyright law was written in 1988 I
believe and
that covered CDs and stuff like that so
it was about consent to record and
consent to copy that AI is taking it and
modifying it and making it into
something new
so we are our issue of course is that
for these games we sign our way our
rights to our voices in those games so
it's actually the games companies that
need to bring these lawsuits at first at
least anyway right thanks for clearing
that up I mean would you accept that
there is a case for using this
technology from time to time I mean Val
Kilmer his voice was destroyed by throat
cancer they've now been able to recreate
his voice as a younger man which again
enables him to make it carry on making a
living
AI isn't evil
um there are it's going to help Humanity
flourish but what we need is regulation
that's the that's the problem we um we
need to make sure that um that the work
that people do is used only for that
work and if it's going to be used for
something else then people need to be
asked for permission I mean consent is
sexy and they need to also be paid for
it
uh very briefly David we haven't got
much time is there any country around
the world that's getting this right in
your opinion uh well I mean China has an
uh AI law but of course there's no
Democratic oversight there the EU is
working on a copyright
um law but they've actually gone back to
the drawing board because of chat gbt uh
chat GPT sorry they've seen that it's
actually very good for the end user for
people Googling and looking things up on
the internet but they want to make sure
that they are dealing with with the big
companies and the uh Big Industry as
well so look to the EU I'd say okay
David gotta leave it there appreciate
you joining me today thank you thank you
that's it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning hope very much to see
you then we've got lots more coming up
after this short break Jillian Joseph's
in Dublin and Anna Jones is here in
London do join them after this short
break thanks for joining me today
cheerio
[Music]
foreign